foreign
[Music]
JK mystery team oh yeah [ __ ] let's see
if any of you guys can figure out this
one word up let's go there's an
Australian actress who's here guilty
left almost I'm with Anthony this
Australian actress is in town and uh in
California and she goes on a date with
somebody right oh really turns out after
that nobody can find her nobody knows
where she went oh but
missing they say she was last seen she's
with Keith Urban dude at a restaurant
Santa Monica and then failed to show up
to her day job and yoga class oh no not
the yoga class turn about her they don't
know what happened to her is she a high
profile actress nah I wouldn't say she's
so she's a professional extra with lines
but that's not the case right now
A-Class extra extra so here's the thing
what do you think happened to her they
already know by now oh they do yeah is
it tragic
could be depends I think nice
I think what happened
was she left with this dude disappeared
they had a sex time she drowned in the
waters of Lake Minnetonka oh they went
away
it's not what it looked
it looks it's not what it looks like and
then the crackhead's like just get rid
of the body they're gonna believe you
and he's like [ __ ]
there's a crackhead roll in this story
yeah I think she went in the uh
celebrity Wax Museum and got lost and
was like [ __ ] everyone here all the
celebrities are in here I need a network
and she just stayed in there and she
just became waxed I need to network with
the celebrities do it one step at a time
then that's tight that's tight one step
at a time all right do you think the guy
she was on date with had anything to do
with it yes okay so yes what what did
this guy do what dating app do they meet
on that doesn't say we're dating app
what the hell where did they meet up at
restaurant in Santa Monica he quaaluded
her and killed her
after he did a touch touch I'm assuming
no death
but I'll still stick to the Quaaludes
okay so she was drugged I think they
went on a cocaine binge and she didn't
show up to work and was uncharacteristic
of her hmm
kind of close all right
drugs are in there drugs are in there
all right so sex a bunch of sex a lot of
love making so it was consensual I hope
it's too sore to go to yoga
actually none of nothing happened with
that dude so huh it's one of those
things where and this is I feel like
this has happened to me too when I
couldn't find somebody but you were the
last one very similar to what happens
when you can't find your car
oh you're gonna find your car yeah you
call the tow truck company usually so if
someone stole it or someone just towed
it away you know like you think you
think someone stole it but really you
did something wrong and it's just gone
so with her at the restaurant this is
all that happened she got a little too
drunk yeah she got some complaints the
cops came to try to calm her down but
she was being more aggressive and when
police try to detain her they say she
became physically combative and then uh
she started kicking officers but bit a
cop on their shoulder oh [ __ ] so that
she was just in jail but she didn't use
her phone call to tell anybody
she got towed yeah she got told she was
parked in illegal Zone towed in
violation but uh people thought she was
stolen so her family in Australia raises
big Ruckus going like something happened
to her we know it's not right like
they're all trying to figure out the
clues she's dressed in jail that's even
more embarrassing internet sleuthing her
she's just in jail it became a Netflix
documentary The GoFundMe and [ __ ] but
how long did it take till people noticed
and what three days what about her
really wasn't her day ain't like yo this
girl oh she just met him she so he
didn't know fat friends and family yeah
yo get your [ __ ] sister dude they are
hardly knew her it's like one of those
so he was just like she's I'm not
swiping right on this [ __ ] next time no
I don't even think he yeah I mean who
knows he might have been at that date
and just been like what yeah
she started biting people he was
probably like and then when the cops
took her away he was like hey stop well
the cops are like is this your girl he's
like nah man
you know my Mom stole my car before when
I when I uh moved in with my dad
continuation hey bar still mad bro
when I moved in with my dad uh in Armani
um my mom let me borrow her car right
and then uh one day I come out and then
I'm like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] my
mom's car what the [ __ ] and I called my
mom I'm like I think your car got stolen
she's like I stole it
what what the so apparently what's
what's the odometer every single week
without me knowing to see how many miles
I've been driving every week what and
then so I think I went over to the Limit
that she was like oh this kid is not
even going to school he's just going all
over the [ __ ] place so she took it
back dang she repoed you she rebooked
she had repoed you bro she repoed your
car so she must have had a friend
because back then there was no Uber yeah
so she had a friend drive her to your
car yeah oh the effort of that my mom's
crazy dude or is it because her son was
crazy and she needed a [ __ ] put it so
normal that boy
do you think you'd have the energy to
parent like your mom yeah that's too
much too much that's very involved like
making sure that you're not [ __ ]
around so when when tyke is old enough
to kind of go wherever he wants would
you want him to share a location at all
times on his phone yeah I would like to
but there's like air tags for that
that's like new tech that makes sense
versus like not using Uber and coming by
and looking at an odometer every week
dude I'm putting my kids like you can
just share a location you know um what
I'm gonna do this is [ __ ] legit I'm
gonna chip myself and the whole family
like put chips in your ass that's gonna
be an option dude like a straight like
dog style right like the vaccine was
like a [ __ ] dolphin GPS tag yeah yeah
what kind would you want any cause like
my [ __ ] how about I just snap it one
tooth that's like wrong it has to be it
has to be like uh like what do you call
it surgically removed to take out
because oh wow I don't want it to be
like a watch what's the point they're
gonna [ __ ] remove it yeah you get
because there's so many like you can get
kidnapped you go [ __ ] hiking every
single time you gotta go through like
TSA metal detectors and you're just like
it's [ __ ] a drag dude there's
Grandma's with a [ __ ] and swords on
their hip you know like swords that's
our femur 100 bad guys with sweats
I'm sure they're pretty close to that
technology yeah
they do have it GPS everybody well don't
they do that with dogs or no yeah they
do with dogs already yeah that's why I'm
like then you won't lose children true
you know like [ __ ] it's like who cares
let them go a mile away you know is it
allowed yet to just like voluntarily be
like hey put I want to lose my kid I
don't think if you could I don't think
you could do it for your child right you
might be able to volunteer to do it for
yourself well I'll be one of them like
the guy who just put the Tesla key in
his like arm or some [ __ ] but if you're
like the legal guardian of your kid
can't you have a safe hell yeah I'll do
it when they're born you know like get
them circumcised yeah you put it chop
off half my dick I mean a third I mean a
ten hey I'll find a vet that would help
me do it you know what I mean there's so
bad I swear that's a dog man it's a
Pomeranian can't you tell you guys never
seen the hairless spider monkeys it's my
child but it's like a spiral small
Japanese boy yeah that's a [ __ ]
hairless spider monkey from South
America so as a homegirl
um everything's just cool now she just
found that's it they [ __ ] got her out
yeah what they thought was gonna be this
crazy ass murder case is really she's
just in jail and she just never a photo
of her what damn freaking always trying
to check girls out and then did she go
like absolutely dude if we can save her
we could save her you know they should
go on like Instagram like hey it's like
a young duck Brown dude
looks like one of my old co-workers she
looks like an X-Men work at the
restaurant it looks like Chris Lilly she
looks like Rogue dude she's like Chris
Lilly from Summer Heights she looks like
summer high is high yo how does she have
like Rogue and poodle hair at the same
time she's Rogue but touched a poodle
for its power do you like her Anthony
um no okay not your type I think uh I
think that shot makes her look less
attractive than I would prefer dude she
does look like a biter though yeah if
there was a picture of a fighter she
looks like a cop she looks like she's uh
privileged enough in her mind to want to
punch cops and [ __ ] like that you know
what the thing is it's like what they
need to do now is normalize families
saying the real [ __ ] about their members
like if the family had just said she's
known to be [ __ ] nuts because what
she did is crazy they say when she got
to the scene the restaurant was saying
she threw a drink at a kid
that kid was asking for it bro he was
running around he was sitting here what
was he wearing yeah yeah it's like
always once they find her the family's
like oh yeah she does have a history of
like kind of losing it like but didn't
you say about first thing they said is
it's not her what where is she at I
don't can't be her no they didn't or
something like that they didn't know
anything they didn't know that she was
in jail or anything just thought they
were just like something happened to her
for sure this is not right you know on
the bright side she's probably really
hard to kidnap you know that would be
nice when the kidnappers like you know
what
that is a good trade you raise a fuss
yeah yeah No One's Gonna Want to kidnap
I hope my kid's hard to kidnap I'm gonna
teach my kids you're just trying to
kidnap somebody you're just profiling
her from the side you're like that one
looks like a rogue poodle yeah not down
not trying to get bit today just the
type of chick where the white van drives
and then the girl just spits out of it
dude you know something too much trouble
like the van's allergic really [ __ ]
nuts another like crazy little little
story one day I was coming home uh from
partying with like Quest guys and then
we were stopping by my parents house and
then uh in Downey it's like really
Suburbia just a bunch of lawns in a row
all right I think it's like 1am there's
this girl just like laying on the lawn
of like two houses down there's no like
young girls that live at my parents like
neighborhood at all so I'm like this is
weird so we get out like why is she just
laying there in like a nice dress and
then she's like kind of coming too and
then she's like oh man like I got I got
she got kicked out of the car and I
don't even know where I am holy [ __ ] she
doesn't and she said she was with some
dudes and they just like ditched her oh
my God kicked her out of the car
literally what did you guys do she I
didn't I didn't want to get honestly I
didn't want to get involved so my rule
is like when I see [ __ ] like that if I
think there's a potential that I'll be
named a suspect for any [ __ ] weird
reason yeah I'm just like all right well
if you're okay I'm going this way she's
like I need help
there's a payphone down the street
super skeptic with these like [ __ ]
seem like I don't know yeah
it's just like so weird to me some
things are set up she just was like
which way is it to Pico you know like
Pico Rivera is right next to Downey and
I was like oh you just go that way it'll
be in Pico right under the freeway and
she's like okay she's like yeah I really
wish I had a ride she looked like she
was like like on some [ __ ] too oh but
she looked like a nice girl otherwise
but she insisted on walking the peak I'm
not gonna [ __ ] she's not coming to my
car yeah yeah so we all of us were just
like what [ __ ] was that was that
like literally like you hear about that
all the time that like girls get like
drug and then just dropped off like
we've seen so many countless stories but
I wouldn't be surprised if that was one
of those ones oh my God my god
um classic Ryan story dude you're wild
dude
[Music]